on sait tous qu'il faut se méfier quand
on utilise son ordinateur dans un
endroit public mais on ne réalise
peut-être pas toujours à quel point les
possibilité d'intrusions dans notre vie
privée sont considérables mathieu du
gabon soit ressources humaines d'abord
quand on parle de données personnelles
qui se retrouvent sur le net de quoi
parle-t-on de quelle quantité mais on
estime selon la firme risque bay
security qui à 800 millions de données
personnelles qu'ils attendraient d'être
consultés ou encore d'être vendus dans
le monde cd des données comme des
numéros de cartes de crédit des dossiers
médicaux des numéros d'assurance sociale
donc c'est énorme
et là vous allez nous parler d'une
expérience qui a été mené assez
récemment la aux pays bas de quoi
s'agit-il il fait juste avant vous
parler de l'expérience et l'union va
regarder une carte derrière moi c'est
une carte qui montre le nombre d'
attaques informatiques qui ont cours
actuellement dans le nôtre c'est en
temps réel ça c'est entre les pays alors
imaginez quand on multiplie par le
nombre d'ordinateurs personnels c'est
vraiment énorme
ce qui est ce qu a eu lieu aux pays-bas
c'est qu'un journaliste a demandé un
pirate de venir avec lui dans un café et
en quelques minutes
le pirate informatique informatique a eu
accès à l'ensemble des données
personnelles de tous les gens qui
étaient branchés à ce moment là le son
de réseaux sans fil du café mais c'est
effrayant comment c'est possible mais
c'est tout simple en fait ça se fait
avec une petite antenne c'est une
attaque qui s'appelle man and the
meadows dont une petite antenne comme
celle on peut vous qu'on peut voir
derrière moi on la cache en dessous d'un
journal et cette antenne la émet un
signal
et c'est un signal qui substitue au
réseau à celui qui est déjà en ligne
dans le café donc les gens ont
l'impression de se connecter sur les
réseaux du café mais ils passent par
l'intermédiaire de l'ordinateur du
pirate donc le pirate accès à l'ensemble
des données de tous les gens qui sont
connectés imaginé en quelques minutes le
pirate est allé voir dans les sites de
rencontres qui avaient été consultés par
ces gens là avaient accès à leurs
dossiers bancaires avaient accès à leur
compte facebook leur mot de passe sur
gmail bref toutes les données qui
étaient dans les ordinateurs qui étaient
branchés à ce moment-là il donc ça peut
se produire dans un endroit public est
ce que ça se peut se produire lhenry
dans les réseaux avec les réseaux qu'on
a chez nous arrive c'est moins fréquent
ça s'appelle le driving donc c'est avec
un une auto ou un camion qui va
pas de chez vous avec une antenne plus
puissante mais c'est beaucoup plus rare
mais ça peut ça peut exister
alors évidemment l'autre question
comment on fait pour se prémunir contre
ce genre d'attaqués
écoutez quand vous êtes dans un endroit
public ne fait jamais de transactions
financières avec des réseaux sans fil
qui sont disponibles il ya les i
toujours avec votre réseau 3g ou 4g dont
celui qui fournit par votre compagnie de
cellulaire aussi utiliser des
applications qui permet de crypter vos
données en a de très bonnes comme par
exemple crypto 4 qui est développée ici
à montréal qui permet de clavarder de
manière plus ou moins anonymes si jamais
à 100% surprotège ça me protège les
communications il ya aussi télégramme
est une autre application qu'on peut
exister on peut utiliser bref
allez-y de manière très parcimonieuse
quand vous êtes dans des cafés dans le
public
jamais de données sensibles sur les
réseaux sans fil qui sont donnés il ya
de très très gros chances que vous soyez
piraté quand vous êtes là bon c'est
assez angoissant mais nous voilà bien un
verre merci beaucoup matière plaisir
céline